don't assume somebody with an American
flag is a conservative
I just there's there's a general sense
of and maybe this is just in my
neighborhood but there's a general sense
of of still everybody's an American
there it isn't they might be a liberal
they might be a conservative I don't
know what their politics are but it like
the American flag for a lot of people in
Liberal cities became this sign I don't
I don't know how conservatives manage to
like capture the American flag as a
symbol but
um they did or maybe the Liberals kind
of gave it to them or surrendered it so
it became this kind of almost people
were embarrassed to have American flags
up so I like that it does I know that
part of it is just that that I run in
more heterodox circles so there seems to
be a lot more diversity of thought